the scene in The Empire Strikes Back
Where Darth Vader is talking to the
bounty hunters
let's take a movie everybody knows Star
Wars Luke Skywalker and Han Solo and
Princess Leia and Chewbacca you know
what I have a new hope for this industry
I'm an obsessive person and I've had so
many obsessions throughout my life Star
Wars being one of them you know Star
Wars is kind of a classic example that I
use you've ever seen Star Wars I'm going
to make a fairy tale for kids because
there are no heroes in movies today
I mean at least that's what he thought
in the early 70s when he first began his
journey of writing the original Star
Wars film if they'd tried to describe
Star Wars before people saw it I don't
think people would have understood what
it was going to be because it sounded
like crap you know this guy travels
around with this big hairy creature and
you know and then there's this guy in a
mask and he's the villain and he's you
know it was but then you see it and what
made Star Wars great was that it was a
visualization of everything we'd been
reading in science fiction for decades
but had never been visualized that well
and so that's what set it apart it
wasn't that it was enormously original
it was that it was transferring to film
what had been we'd been reading about
forever but had never seen on film so
that was what made it so exciting you
know flying through the asteroid belt
and all those wonderful things the laser
battles and you name it it was it was
great fun it's one of the most
entertaining films ever made Star Wars
was like a instant hit you know and uh
that summer but then who knew it would
grow into such a franchise and uh
you know it just went from strength to
strength until it's
I guess the world's biggest franchise
right now huh it's fascinating to look
at that case study because yeah you have
two films that had similar budgets both
had similar type of filmmakers they were
targeting a very similar audience
they're released at the same time like
everything is the same one becomes a
really good movie that people love and
actually did pretty well Close
Encounters in the Third Kind another uh
becomes a 50 billion dollar brand and so
what there's a variable in there
somewhere that created that separation
in the marketplace and uh week weekend
we can look at that and probably guess
pretty closely why that happened uh
there's a book that I read recently
called how Star Wars conquered the
universe where they asked Steven
Spielberg this exact same question and
uh because him and him and Lucas would
actually give each other producer points
on all of their movies and see yeah so
so uh Lucas had producer points on Close
Encounters Spielberg had producer points
in Star Wars obviously Spielberg got a
better part of that deal but and they
said well why you know why did it work
out so well uh for Lucas and you know
pretty well for you but it's not even in
the same ballpark he said there's two
reasons he said from the beginning Lucas
approached this project not as just a
single film he always had a broader
Vision he understood that there was
story before this there's going to be a
story after this maybe he didn't have
all the things planned out exactly and
have it all worked out but his vision
was very big from the beginning and
secondly he said he had a world that
people wanted to explore hit a story
world he said I never even gave any a
thought of my story world the setting of
Close Encounters was our world that's
just being invaded by aliens but what he
did he created a world that people
wanted to continue to explore
and and and if you can create a world in
an IP an intellectual property that
people want to continue to explore
then all of a sudden that then makes the
room for the other things that you want
to do and so you know what's really
interesting about Lucas in the same book
is that he didn't grow up wanting to be
a filmmaker he wanted he grew up wanting
to be an architect and he he worked at
his dad's toy store every summer as a
kid and so he approached filmmaking not
from the filmmaking standpoint he
approached it from a architectural and
toy standpoint and and and he still went
in to make a good movie of course but he
then approached it the the industry and
the creative and the writing of it in a
completely different way that then
fueled all these opportunities when you
look at the very first Star Wars movie
George Lucas
I know I bring it up a lot but Star Wars
was influenced by many things you know
cereals from the 1930s
um from things like Flash Gordon and
Buck Rogers I mean George Lucas famously
just wanted to make Flash Gordon but had
trouble with getting the rights it was
influenced by Marvel Comics it was
influenced by a tragic event where he
almost died
um in a car accident
and was in the hospital for a long
period of time
and that near-death experience
changed George Lucas
much much of his influence was from also
his father
in his life who was a successful
business person who he looked up to
a lot of his experience was growing up
in in Modesto
people you know the obsession over car
culture
and hot rods
when you see that in the character of
Han Solo you know it's kind of a guy
who's into hot rods the Millennium
Falcon is a hot rod but so much of the
influences that George had both from
life and so much uh classic literature
and storytelling we're kind of thrown in
a blender George called Star Wars the
most expensive low budget movie ever
made
he's always retired now but George was
um
very very good to work with
he he really knew what he wanted and and
where he was going with it and he knew
what you he wanted you to do so
um I really enjoyed the fact that he was
so prepared
he also had
um
he had a technique which we now call a
rip-o-matic
and that technique was to he got footage
from uh Old World War II movies like The
Dam Busters and Torah Tora Tora and he
basically cut
his and action sequence out of footage
from these World War II movies
and then that became a template for the
effects because you know you'd you'd go
to the cut and you'd say okay I need a
ship moving from left to right and
another one coming in this way and
um it's going to be 17 frames long so it
was a way of
um you know they have whole departments
and movies now called previous
for doing this kind of work now but back
then this was a technique I'd never seen
before and uh it worked really really
well the three second rule is if you're
creating a world or an immersive
experience
if your audience member doesn't
understand the world they're in in three
seconds or less
then you have not successfully
um suspended their disbelief and this
idea came uh you know the first time I
heard it was a story about George Lucas
when he was creating his um the Star
Wars universe is that when an audience
member looks at a Star Wars world and if
it doesn't feel and he was creating it
you know if it doesn't feel like
something that belonged in the world he
was creating then it does not belong
um so it was a really interesting way to
look at the world that you're creating
to make sure that it's consistent
throughout your whole experience and if
you're creating something that is truly
immersive then it should feel immersive
from every to every single detail from
beginning to end if you look at from the
original Star Wars movie the uh the
Cantina scene where Luke and Obi-Wan
they go into the Cantina and there's all
those crazy aliens around and they as
this is where they find Han Solo for the
first time
there was there was a very specific
choice of of I want these crazy aliens
all around they could have had to cut
back on budget they could have had
everybody look human like Luke if they
wanted to but instead he really made
sure that every single character in that
bar and in that Cantina had a very
distinctive look that they they seemed
mysterious that they it was obvious that
all of them had some sort of backstory
involved and just that creative won the
writing decision to the directorial
decision if you watch the scene the way
they made sure they got shots of all of
them there were interesting ones in the
foreground in the background they took
time in the in the edit of the film to
to cut cut and show a handful of them
then those creative opportunities both
in the writing the directing and the
editing then fueled short stories in
video games and cartoons that dealt with
all of them they created web content for
all of them they created game content
for all of them and they created toys
for all of them so now all of a sudden
where most filmmakers and directors
would say my scene is about my
protagonist and my antagonist and the
characters are Central characters
everything else is background
Lucas never considered anybody
background he looked at all these other
characters as potential stories
potential stories potential stories that
just so happened to be in the background
of this scene but I'm going to develop
all of them as if they could be the
heroes of Their Own Story and then put
them in the background Grandma Tarkin
walks in the room Darth Vader walks the
room they and they they're having a
council meeting right on the Death Star
and he talks about the emperor has wiped
away the Imperial Senate they'll not be
a concern for us I'm not quoting it
correct directly but that's the basic
line well one I'm an audience member one
who are all these evil men in this room
right this is already scary secondly
wait there's an emperor of the Galaxy
and there's an imperial Senate who is
this emperor of the Galaxy There Was An
Imperial Senate why were they wiped away
my imagination as a kid
was utilized because characters in the
movie talked about off-screen events
happening
and I think that that is a device that
is underused so going back to Star Wars
did you see Star Wars so going back to
start
an unlikable character
um might be better way to describe Han
Solo in the first Star Wars movie where
he was kind of uh he was selfish he was
out for himself he only cared about
money didn't care about the cause that
the that Princess Leia was on and he was
you know parts of him were unlikable he
was still it's look it's Harrison Ford
he's very attractive man that chiseled
Jaw sure I'm very envious of that be
mean to me yeah exactly if it's me so
but he's you know
um he's unlikable and has a Redemption
right so that Redemption Arc is
important not just you know and we've
seen it happen more with villains Darth
Vader well I would say the greatest
villain in movie history is Darth Vader
that that would be a great villain that
comes to mind the emperor is the
ultimate antagonist he believes he's not
just
being evil for the sake of being evil
he's he thinks he's bringing peace and
order to the uh to the to the Galaxy
like without his agenda you know it's
he's like he's the ultimate believer and
you got to break a few eggs if you want
to make an omelet you know if he doesn't
if he doesn't do what he's going to do
the the entire universe will fall into
into you know some sort of state of
you know of total chaos you know where
he says okay look you know maybe I have
gotta I've got to destroy a couple of
planets to achieve my my goal but if I
don't even more planets will get
destroyed because there'll be such chaos
you know you know it needs like a firm
hand you know on the uh you know on you
know ruling the universe so so he has to
believe that yeah yeah people are not
going to like my methods but now but
give it some time and people will and
Darth Vader to me is the combination of
probably some of the best aspects of of
villains from all types uh you know
whether it be from you know movie
serials or comic books it's
fairly easy to argue that Darth Vader
was very influenced by Dr Doom from the
Fantastic Four comic books created by
Stan Lee the look of Darth Vader kind of
based on that also based on a little bit
of a samurai in there
um in terms of the helmet and other
aspects of Darth Vader's character and
the fact that it took you know
uh you know David prowse is an actor uh
and then James Earl Jones as a voice
actor to kind of create this and also
the physical look you know the costume
designers and and whatnot and and Ralph
bakshi to kind of design the character
or versions of the character to what it
became on screen so so much went into
the creation of Darth Vader as a villain
and that Darth Vader has a tragic
backstory that only a piece of it
becomes revealed in the second movie in
which Darth Vader appeared The Empire
Strikes Back
uh you know villains have layers the
scene in The Empire Strikes Back Where
Darth Vader's talking to the bounty
hunters could have been between Darth
Vader and Boba Fett there didn't have to
be any other characters there just Darth
Vader saying Boba Fett go catch Han Solo
but Lucas made the creative decision in
the story to have Boba Fett and eight
other bounty hunters there in that scene
now what that did that creative decision
then spurred a whole other product that
was part of the business plan which was
this anthology of short stories that
existed in the marketplace to engage the
fan base and generate Revenue that all
was was premised and created and birthed
out of the creative decision of the
writer and director to have multiple
characters in the scene when George
Lucas was mapping out the story for The
Empire Strikes Back
he realized that the audience would
never believe that you would kill Luke
Skywalker
so you have this lightsaber Duel at the
end of The Empire Strikes Back and it's
Luke Skywalker fighting Darth Vader
where's the tension
because we already know he's making a
Trilogy you're not going to kill off
Luke Skywalker
so there's really no drama or tension in
that scene so what Lucas did he's like
okay since they the audience is not
going to believe that I would kill Luke
Skywalker
what if the real drama the real threat
is that Luke might turn to the dark side
and because he he he doesn't listen to
Yoda's advice he doesn't complete his
training he goes off as as not a fully
trained Jedi
and faces his greatest Nemesis who he
then learns at the end of the after
losing that fight that it's his father
could he turn to the dark side and and
George Lucas believed that the audience
might believe that he would turn to the
dark side I promised I would tell them
the story of Luke becoming a Jedi like
his father I promised that I would tell
the story of Luke saving the princess I
promised I would tell the story about
trying to stop the Death Star and if you
look at the story Every Beat
is something about one of those three
components and you know if it's like cut
to you know Luke goes to a pet shop and
decides that he wants to buy a dog you
go
it might be the sweetest cutest most fun
scene you know in the history of fun
scenes but you know it's not moving the
story forward even Star Wars is is
thematically Rich but we don't think
about it because we we're thinking about
the you know the Space Opera part of it
and the technology and the good versus
evil but there is a character Arc in
there and it's an actually a thematic
argument through the story about what
it's about you know it's usually an
argument between two things
um and in Star Wars it's it's technology
versus the energy the force and if you
look at the scenes and you really pay
attention to what they're talking about
even Darth Vader
makes that argument in the scenes with
uh with his superiors with the the
whatever whoever Peter Cushing plays
it's not the M but the emperor no it's
not the emperor but whoever his boss
and all these scenes you have where he
talks about the dark side of the force
and then the other side is talking about
the power of the death star of
technology and that's the argument and
then Luke and Obi-Wan have the argument
about the force and owning the force and
if you look at the last moment that
moment where Luke has to decide versus
the force
and Technology right the targeting
system and at the last second he makes
that choice that's his Epiphany that's
the the decision he could have kept you
know he could have chosen the other
thing could have just technology with
the force that would have been a
different story
right we're saying well technology is
more important than the force in this
case Lucas wanted to show that the force
is more important than technology and
that's what Luke's decision that's what
he showed and that's that was what the
audience audiences walked away from Luke
is asking the question what's more
powerful Faith or technology and he
grapples with that throughout the entire
story right everything is about you know
is about that
um the all the bad guys have no such
questions they make the argument
technology is strong like Darth Vader is
a result of Technology he had faith and
it didn't
save him back when he had his fight with
Obi-Wan
so Faith let him down he's now surviving
based on technology the Death Star is a
giant ball of flashy blinky technology
right it's like you know the faith is
gone from the universe right you my
friend are all that's left of you know
your faith or whatever you know whatever
is said to him
um so the bad guys have no such
questions they are convinced they make
the argument that that technology is
stronger than faith Luke is uncertain
and what does he learn finally at the
end is that faith and Technology can
work together right and that's where you
get the ultimate strength right because
he uses
he uses when he destroys the Death Star
he shuts off the targeting computer
which is him rejecting technology use
the force Luke right he's embracing
Faith but it's like it's not like he
does one of you know the Obi-Wan two
finger air move and the death star
explodes he still uses technology to
destroy the death story right he uses
the Torpedoes so he's using technology
in in concert with faith and that's the
strongest of all so it's really an
interesting lesson right that you don't
have to you don't have to reject you
don't have to be Amish right where
you're rejecting technology right and
you don't have to be you know sort of a
scientific atheist where you're
completely rejecting Faith you can be
somebody who's embracing everything that
the world has to offer in terms of both
spirituality and technology and that's
where you get you sort of a complete
person so so for me that's how you tell
a story uh Luke gets to the planet the
last Rebel Planet uh Darth has followed
him there with a homing Beacon he's got
a death star he's gonna blow up the
whole damn thing there's nothing Luke
can do about it there's just a little
few starfighters and he's got a death
star that's it the movie's over and then
of course
stole the plan
to really get close and Luke you can the
only one get that missile in that hole
if you use the force not your computer
and so the obstacle point is All Is Lost
and the climaxes Luke learns the theme
of the story
gluc will you use the force to rescue
the princess and save the Republic he
puts his computer away all the other
starfighters used it they couldn't get
the missile in he puts his computer away
he's learned he hears oh we want to say
Luke use the force not the computer and
he puts the missile in the whole climax
so the obstacle point is always lost and
the climax is Luke you did it what's the
the central question of Star Wars the
professional question is will
um will Luke destroy the Death Star
right the
um
personal question is will he save
Princess Leia
and the private question is will he be a
Jedi like his father right so if you
look at Star Wars you know the
professional personal and private you go
that all three of those get answered
right at the climax of the movie right
he destroys the Death Star so sure he
went in and he saved Princess Leia from
the jail cell but they let him get away
because they would lead him to the rebel
base right and
um
the the way of saving Princess Leia for
real because she's on the planet that
the Death Star is about to destroy right
so the way to save Princess Leia
ultimately is to destroy the Death Star
and the way to destroy the Death Star is
he's got all the technology and stuff
that he's using but he shuts it off and
he uses the force so in one Fell Swoop
right in One Moment In the climax he
uses the force saves the princess by
destroying the Death Star so the central
question is answered in the affirmative
yes yes and yes yeah will he yeah will
he save Princess Leia yes will he
destroy the Death Star yes will he
become a Jedi like his father yes so we
started shooting these explosions and we
would shoot I would look directly up at
his explosion so they would explode over
the lens and therefore give it the zero
g
impression that it was happening in
outer space because obviously if you if
you shouldn't an explosion normally you
get a big mushroom cloud and it doesn't
doesn't look like it's in outer space so
uh we started off letting these little
bombs off and it was
um
quite successful and shooting them with
high-speed cameras and then we got
bigger and bigger and we moved on to
much bigger stages until eventually we
we had like a 40-foot blue screen
and we would drop the wire down in the
middle of that blue screen and we would
light the blue screen with like I think
there were uh eight Arc lamps you know
which were the most powerful lamps that
you could get in those days
and uh shooting them with a Vista vision
camera
and we would we would shoot up through a
piece of glass which was with two saw
horses and a piece of plywood and a hole
cut out to shoot through and then a
piece of glass was over that to protect
the lens and then we we let off these
bigger and bigger bombs until finally we
had the uh the explosions that we needed
for blowing up the uh the Death Star and
also for blowing up older on All the
Monies up on the screen the only view
they really had to pay real money to
were Alec Guinness and Peter Cushing
because we were pretty much all unknowns
half of the fun of some of these
characters from the Star the world of
Star Wars is the fact that we didn't
know anything about them that we could
use our imagination professionally and
also in terms of quality it's like if I
was going to do that I'd need to hire
Mark Hamill like you know there'd be no
there'd be no gray area it's okay I mean
people come up and say I'm really sorry
I've never seen Star Wars so that's fine
I'm not upset it's okay it's not for
everybody
you know
like I say The Young and the mentally
young those are the ones that really are
our biggest fans uh there's something to
be said about uh
it appeals to the child in all of us
because you see grown men
policemen and firemen who are authority
figures let down their guard and become
nine years old again like when you post
with this lightsaber really you were
just about to arrest me
now you're my friend uh it's been
amazing because I I I I never expected
it to have this sort of longevity or the
impact on these people and you meet
people all the time they said I became
what I became because of that movie so
it's quite uh it's awesome when you
think about the the
the impact that it's had
after all these years I certainly never
thought I'd be still talking about it
something else that occurs to me also
um related to Star Wars yes a recurring
Topic in conversations that I will have
with you and that I have with my friends
often
you know maybe it's a form of therapy I
look at the Star Wars films and and just
with with immense respect
for how they've been able to keep that
IP alive over 60 years or 50 years
however long it's been how much they've
been able to scale the brand how long
they've been able to sustain the fan
community and create the culture that
they have uh to continue to to push
artistic boundaries of what they're
doing with the Mandalorian and the
volumetric capture stage that they built
and and uh just you know the
storytelling of the Mandalorian what
they're doing what they're doing now
with all the crossover stuff that that
on Disney plus is absolutely incredible
you have somebody like a character like
Ahsoka Tano I'm going to get Star Wars
nerdy for a second you have you have a
character like Ahsoka Tano who's a
character from The Clone Wars animated
series that they then pull into a
different animated series Star Wars
Rebels that they then pull into a live
action series of the Mandalorian uh in
Casa live action actress and now I'm
gonna spin her off to her own
live-action series on Disney plus what
they're doing from a trans me in a
transmission media sense is just really
super interesting and and how they
revived the Star Wars Let me see the
revive the star it's not like it was
dead but like the way they brought Star
Wars back in front of culture with baby
Yoda and and now we know as grogu but
but ever like everybody was talking
about baby Yoda just a cultural
sensation of baby Yoda it's just a
really smart
interesting
choices that they make and especially
now start they just uh they have
something now called Star Wars Visions
where they it's it's uh it's um animated
short films that are all done created in
the manga style uh so you like uh
Japanese animation is all done in with
with manga creators uh telling manga
stories uh in the Star Wars universe
that are very much catered to uh to a
completely new market a younger Market a
more Eastern Market where Star Wars
hasn't been able to really get a
foothold as a brand very much and and
and and it works and it's good and it's
and it's it's powerful storytelling and
um so I I appreciate them
as a fan I appreciate them as a
filmmaker and I appreciate them as
somebody who understands how to build
and sustain IP like the way they do it
is just a master class on on how to keep
an engine like that running and not just
running but thriving in the midst of
multiple multiple decades this really is
a tremendous thing and it all goes back
to how George Lucas
created and built the whole thing it's
really like he he approached it in a
unique way and they've continued to to
keep that going did you never outgrew
you outgrow these things right you said
there was a point where I like Star Wars
because basically oh our fans are The
Young and the mentally Young no my point
I've never outgrown Star Wars my point
was that uh there was a specific time
where I was probably the most obsessed
about it now it's turned into a minor
Obsession
okay just checking